foreign
I wrote this journal entry in 2013.
I've been sleeping restlessly for months
there's a constant feeling of tension in
my body
I love ministry as a Catholic priest
the opportunity to share my faith with
people and support them as we journey
through life together
but I have a desire to share my life
with another person
I knew in Discerning Ministry that
celibacy not getting married was part of
the package
but I don't know if I can do this any
longer
I'm rarely alone
but I feel bitterly lonely
I wrote this when I was on the cusp of
making one of the biggest and most
significant
decisions of my life
whether to lead ministry as a Catholic
priest
I think my life has been a reasonably
unique and unusual one now in my early
40s I've had careers as an opera singer
a Catholic priest
a corporate lawyer
and now a Management Consultant
and when people hear the careers that
I've had
the most common question I get asked
maybe the one that's on your mind
is what on Earth is the connection
amongst it at all
through all of these changes
through all of these careers
one constant has been present
the practice of reflection
now people may think that reflection is
something that happens in a dark private
room like Candlelight or flashlight to
purge one's deepest darkest secrets
but I want to bring this practice out of
the dark and into the light
I want to share how this practice can
help our everyday lives and especially
our work lives
I want to share how this practice helps
to improve performance
to make better decisions both big and
small
and to build better relationships
interestingly in a 2020 survey of some 4
000 respondents conducted by BCG and bva
the question was asked
what makes a good leader
what are their main qualities and skills
notably possessing a good capacity for a
reflection was listed as one of the top
five skills
the others being empathy
listening
consideration and team development
reflection is about learning
it's about looking at the events of our
lives without judgment but with a
critical lens
I really like the way leadership
professors James Bailey and shaherazade
Raymond describe it
it requires taking an honest moment to
look at what transpired
what worked what didn't
what can be done and what can't
reflection requires courage
it's thoughtful and it's deliberate
so how do we do this then let's take a
look at sports I grew up in Australia
and one of the most popular games played
was cricket
consistent high performance from batters
Bowlers and fielders is essential
but given it's a team sport it's not
just about how the team the individual
performs but about how the team performs
collectively together
cricketers reflect during a game after a
game and over time
during a game they might think about a
missed catch or how they could bat or
Bowl better the next delivery
after a game they might come together to
watch video replays to look at what
worked and what didn't
which might differ from what they
actually experienced during the game
itself
and then over time they might look to
the patterns of their wins and losses to
gleam even more meaningful conclusions
and insights
the same process can and should be used
in the workplace and I don't think we
need to watch video replays of our
meetings to dissect what took place
I don't know about you but that might
feel kind of creepy
reflection can be done through a variety
of different formats purposeful thinking
written journal entries audio notes
pictures a discussion with a mentor or
honest friend
the point is to find what works for you
and to make a regular commitment
to examine the events and experiences of
your lives what worked what didn't and
why and then to think about what and how
you would like to do things differently
next time
when we practice reflection as a habit
we gain even more meaningful Insight
because we see patterns that reflection
on Standalone events doesn't provide
I truly think reflection can help
everyone people in every industry at
every stage of one's career and in every
point in one's life
let me share with you an example that I
think most people can connect with
most of us have meetings
I was due for a daily catch-up with a
colleague he had just led a client
meeting for the first time it was to
give a progress update on the work
stream that he was responsible for in
this project
he said to me that the meeting had gone
terribly
he didn't get through the actions taken
he wasn't able to discuss the obstacles
face or the decisions required he didn't
get to the next steps or the responsible
persons
he felt
angst uneasy upset
he was concerned about what the client
had thought of him in the meeting but
more importantly what the client felt
about the work that was going on in the
work stream
it would have been so easy for him to
have just pushed past this to try and
suppress the emotions but that would
have missed a massive opportunity
we took a few moments to to think and
objectively reflect over what took place
and then to put in place some
commitments as to what and how he could
do things differently next time
he decided that in future he would start
each meeting with an agenda alignment to
make sure there was Clarity on what
needed to be achieved
and then he'd resolve to make sure that
he would take greater control over the
meeting so that if topics came up beyond
the scope of the agenda that he'd note
that a separate discussion should be had
reflection helps to improve performance
reflection helps to make better
decisions imagine for a moment you've
been in your current role for five years
it's a creative role
but you don't quite feel you've got that
Zing that energy for it anymore
you've been offered another opportunity
in the organization uh it's actually a
promotion it's a more senior role it's
managerial
but you'll have responsibility for
looking after 12 director reports
a competitors also recently reached out
to you they've offered you an
opportunity for the same kind of role
that you've got currently
but it pays a higher salary
there's a big difference between being a
creative and being a manager
so what is it that really makes you
happy
what is it that really makes you
fulfilled
reflection provides a treasure Trove of
data to help you work through this
have your Reflections mentioned being
bored with projects or do you just want
to try something new
would you like to be a manager would you
like to see people grow and form and
develop them
do you think you could do a better job
than your own manager
reflection provides great insight
it's easy to get lost when you've got an
opportunity of a fancier job title or
more money
but reflection enables you to focus on
what really matters and to make better
choices
let me share with you a final example
most of us have relationships in our
work bosses customers clients suppliers
whomever
and I think most of us try to have good
relationships with these people
if I'm honest while I strive for this
ambition I haven't always succeeded
but reflection has helped me to build
better relationships
a number of years ago I was giving a
feedback session with a colleague
and after having done so I took a few
moments to jot down some thoughts as to
how it went
I realized I had been too clinical in
fact if only you could have seen the
Expressions on my colleague's face
I'd raced through their various
strengths and moved on to spending more
time on their areas for development
if I'd really thought about this person
I would have spent far greater time
actually on their strengths and actually
emphasizing why they were such a
valuable member of our organization
and then creating a space where they
felt psychologically safe to be able to
go on and explore these areas for
development
reflection has helped me to improve this
and to build better relationships
so this might all sound a little fine
and dandy and and maybe obvious or
trivial
but the truth is so many of us don't
take time out for regular reflection
this practice has helped me
and I am so grateful
after I left being a priest
I took some time out for reflection to
think about who I was and what I wanted
my life to be about
reflection helped me to Grapple with
this and it continues to help me today
as I grew up with this and other topics
so as we end this day
or tomorrow before you begin the next
sit down
take a breath and reflect
and you'll see the power that this habit
brings to your life
thank you